hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals uh
oh well the grand final of the magnus
crossing chester we are continuing with
the third match dingler and versus
magnus carlsen uh in the first match
ding was victorious then magnus
retaliated in the second one and now we
have the third match like we said it's
the best of five
whereas the finals is the best of seven
and the winner from magnus and ding will
face the winner of uh nakamura versus
daniel dubo and they will of course face
him face off in the finals
so this uh already quite an interesting
game it's a game two from their third
match a game one ended in a draw the one
where ding had the white pieces and now
this one is is quite interesting so
let's just check it out uh and it's
interesting that both magnus and the
ding
with the black pieces went for the
sicilian in the third match so let's see
what happens we have e4 c5
then goes for the sicilian defense
knight f3 d6 and
d4 so no funny business immediately
striking in the center
captures captures knight f6 knight f3
and knight c3 and a6
that night of sicilian is on the board
we have bishop e3 magnus goes for the
bayern attack
uh and we have e5 here challenging the
knight pushing the knight back
knight b3 and bishop to e6 so this is
all very standard
uh queen d2 preparing f3 pushing on the
king side maybe queen side castles
and so on so bishop e7 biting and now
f3 going for this uh pushes on the king
side
and now although castles is the most
common move here ding first goes h5 he
doesn't want to allow magnus to
easily start attacking so he controls
the g4 square so bishop p2 prepares g4
somewhat
and now knight bd7 this knight is now
coming to c5 or b6
depending on what black what white plays
and not knight to d5 a signature
neither of move uh when you're playing
with the white pieces uh
sometimes you'll just put it there as
it's an excellent square for the knight
sometimes you will capture something
there sometimes you will
sacrifice the knight on d5 so everything
is possible and
most often uh the black player will
capture with the knight here and shift
the bishop over to this diagonal
will be quite useful there but here dean
goes for the somewhat rarer bishop
captures on the e5
and okay pawn captures and now already
as of move
12 we have a new move that is b6 so
already
a completely new game uh being uh
reluctant to go for b5 right away maybe
the knight a5 going to c6 allows a bit
too much for white so thing will
postpone uh pushing
the of the pawn all the way to b5 so
first he goes b6
and now uh just uh a nice
queen side castle by magnus ah so here
queen c7
now ding wants to go a rook to c8b5
bring the knight to b6 to c4 and so on
the usual night of attacking stuff
king b1 a nice prophylactic move by
magnus and now
b5 advancing the pawn all the way
knight to a5 now the c6 square is
available for the white knight but also
the c4 square is available for ding's
knight so knight to b6 coming to c4
and magnus says of course i don't want
to allow this then i'd have to capture
it then you get an open b
file so better just to give up the
bishop pair now and eliminate your
strong knight
so queen captures and now knights the c6
finally carlson's knight is uh
activated on this beautiful c6 outpost
and now
bishop to d8 if the knight is if the
bishop is captured
at some point you don't have to mess up
your castling privileges and here's c4
it's always uh interesting how this c4
movie is played sometimes in positions
with opposite sides castling
uh because it seems counterintuitive to
open up the b
file for black to attack i mean you even
force it open uh but the point is that
after captures and captures
you've activated your bishop somewhat
but also it doesn't matter how many
pieces
black has on the b file for example with
b3 this bishop
on battery is just uh unbreakable even
if a5 a4 is possible it is just a
unbreakable setup so here uh being
castles and rook h to e1 now the rooks
have been centralized and the
magnus will be looking into something
like h3 g4
uh and so on maybe even f4 trying to
bust open uh bust open the center to get
a maybe a
nice pass deep on so here at knight to
d7
uh and now comes g4 so here
being either can wait for the g file to
open up or he can play captures captures
and
now continue the game with bishop to h4
which he does
pushes the rook somewhere else but
magnus says i'm not interested in that
g5 and here it's really really a
beautiful beautiful idea
uh point is if the rook is captured
knight e7 check wins the game
because after the king moves queen
captures there is no defense against
mate here
as the knight covers both of these
squares it's uh
it's game over for example this is just
a nice mate into king eg7 king h6
checkmate
so here after g5 dingo's g6 first
uh now makes some room for the king and
g7 but now rook f1 magnus just gets the
rook out of the way
king g7 now preparing to shift the rooks
over to the h file and the queen to g2
now magnus wants to bring the queen into
the game
via uh this plan so rook to
h 8 by ding and now queen g4 attacking
the knight but uh
thinks is not a problem i'm just going
to play queen c7 and defend everything
however
this is a big problem so pause the video
here and figure out why this is a big
problem for ding
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
black is either getting checkmated or
loses a queen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook captures an f7
beautiful stuff beautiful stuff king
captures queen e6 czech
king has to if you go here then rook f1
wins so you have to go to g7 but now
knight e7 going for g6
and now there's there's no defending g6
for example if knight f8 you just go
check king h7 and
mate beautiful stuff so after 97
black's only defends his queen captures
on c4 to guard that f1 square not
allowing rook f1
allow this and after king f8 uh now go
knight to f5 and there's no defense
against this mate
uh queen g7 check followed by this
checkmate uh
if this then this is mate in one so the
only thing black has here is check
king here and now give up the queen but
that's of uh
of little help because i mean it's just
uh it
is just uh too good of a position for
white you're gonna eliminate
this pawn next you're gonna get a nice
pass deep on so
black does have some material
compensation but not with the king on e7
not not quite
so after queen c7 this wins the game on
the spot however magnus decides to
prepare it with rook to f3
now this row can come to f1 going after
the f7
pawn so ding immediately advances it
with f5
now uh g captures on f6 upper song
and knight captures on f6 uh we have
queen to g2 preparing to shift this rook
over here go after the g6 pawn queen d7
uh and now preparing if this rook ever
moves you can then shift the queen over
to f5 with some checking
ideas so rogue g1 attacking on g6 and
now
rook h6 defending with a3 by magnus
magnus knows what's happening he wants
to
have the a2 square available to the king
if needed
so knights to h5 and now rook to b3
uh so there you have it uh claiming the
b file for the rook
uh and now knight to f4 attacking the
queen queen has to move queen
c2 and now ding wants to play queen f5
to trade queens however queen captures
and
you cannot capture the g pawn is pinned
so ding prepares it with king to h8
but that's why magnus played a3 king to
a2 now he doesn't want to trade queens
of course
queen f5 biting and now queen d2 by
magnus
so queen to e4 ding manages to
infiltrate uh
with the queen attacking the bishop and
rook c1 and now you can see all of a
sudden
uh magnus had a completely winning game
but now all of his pieces shifted from
attacking being skiing to the queen side
and it's actually ding who has a past e
pawn so it's a it's a very interesting
position so here we have bishop g5
threatening some nasty discoveries but
magnus says uh not a problem uh rook to
c3 because
with the queen and the rook here it's
very hard to decide what the plate the
knight can just jump anywhere
so magnus finds the very interesting
rook seat the c3 saying i don't mind any
discoveries
but it also allows dink to completely
trade down into a
uh well into it into a very interesting
end game so knight e6
opens up an attack on carlson's queen
queen c2 and now
queen captures on c2 we have rook
captures and the knights the d4
attacking both rooks so now magnus heads
has to
uh give up his uh excellent knight on
the c6 output so captures capture is
doing now already with the past
d4 pawn and rook to b6 with
bishop to f4 now defending this also
preparing to capture here and now
of course magnus goes for the pawn here
so he gets two connected pass pawns on
the queen side so
captures captures and captures and now
dink has to decide whether it's okay to
capture an h3 but the thing is it's not
because if you capture magnus gladly
trades and now just pushes his pawn his
pawns are much faster
for example g5 you're gonna go bishop e2
you can't push right away because this
blocks your light square bishop so this
becomes possible
so king g7 you're gonna go a4 king f6
you're gonna go king b3 you have to
reach c4 so the black king cannot
capture this and now you're just better
whatever you play
this i mean this is just winning there's
not much you can do here
so uh even if you try something like
this and the g4
it's not a problem you can push your b5
g3 block the
dg2 light square and that's just it it's
uh again completely winning for for
white
so now after bishop captures an a6 then
goes to rook to h3 and ding says okay i
now control d3 square i control d2
square i'm just going to push the pawn
to victory
but magnus says no you're not he pushes
a4 and now this is uh
this is uh not possible because of rook
c3 beautiful stuff
d2 rook captures with check that's the
point and you don't have time to promote
to a queen king g7 you're just gonna
block the queening square
uh beautiful stuff so after a4 king g7
and now rook to f2 now magnus again
doesn't allow the pushing of the pawn
not because if you push just uh well
captures is possible with captures
so bishop e3 but now bishop f1
not allowing a moment's rest for ding to
start pushing his d pawn
so rook h5 getting out of the way but
now rogue g2
and now yes ding gets to grab the d51
ready to push his pass deep on the rook
is behind the pass pawn but bishop d3
blocks the pawn
and also goes after the g6 pawn so rook
g5
the only way for ding to defend it but
now magnus very gladly trades captures
captures and even though we're
in an opposite color bishop end game
it's not a problem because
magnets has two connected pass pawns
endings ding spawn is a double d point
which the lights for bishop is very
nicely blocking so here
a5 by magnus bishop d8 it's essential to
control
the a7 square a6 with bishop to b6 and
now king to b3 the king is just coming
here
and that's going to be game king f6 we
have king c4 we have king to e5 king b5
attacks the bishop
bishop a7 and now king to c6 and it was
in this position on mu 55 that
dingle iron resigned the game and game
two goes to magnus
with this uh well almost a brilliancy
with the rook captures
on f7 but uh he he just decided to
try down into an end game and the ding
was not the the most precise uh
uh person about the end game so here he
resigns because
you don't have a lot to do this just
wins the game on the spot let's say you
try king f4
b for king e3 you can just move the
bishop you can just give up the bishop
here you don't really care you're just
going to push the pawn and that's it if
it is this
captures captures push push not with the
king obviously but
with the pawn and after you move your
king white gets just a
queen into the game and that's just it
so
once again i do hope you enjoyed it and
as promised here is a nice photo of
meadow swimming in the sea
also also myself there you have it uh he
was
really unnatural he didn't like dive in
right away
uh because he he never saw the sea or
tasted it
he first tried drinking it but then he
realized he was salty
so you know not cool uh but we had some
extra water with us so of course he was
uh
replenished right away but then after i
got into the water then he just followed
and it was a it was a
very enjoyable experience for for both
of us so
that's uh the the game and a nice photo
of mirror for you as
promised uh i would like to thank uh
stephen owens andre smallnik of david
kimura paula
and lars evan almas for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
uh thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
magnus carlsen grand final checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day
and now i'm gonna turn on the air
conditioning because it's way too loud
to have it on while recording
see you soon